today we'll spill the tea on taurine
you'll learn that it's an unusual amino
acid that is used not for proteins but
has other responsibilities
from there we'll look at this recent
investigation that found taurine
supplementation extended lifespan and
some models and delays aging
so let's spill some tea
firstly what actually is taurine well
it's an amino acid it has an amino group
and an acid group but it's a special
kind it's a special kind because when we
think about amino acids we usually mean
there's plenty different amino acids
that are combined to make proteins
but taurine is chemically different and
has a sulfonic acid instead of a
carboxylic acid group and is therefore
not inserted into proteins
asset is not bound up in proteins
taurine is referred to as a free amino
acid is a free air it's not used to make
protein then what is it doing
well many many roles have been
attributed to taurine it can be
conjugated to boil acids and this
influences fat absorption and absorption
of fat soluble vitamins
it's also been attributed as an
inhibitory neurotransmitter
Turin looks a little bit like the
neurotransmitter Gaba and it binds the
Gaba receptor as well as the glycotine
receptor
and Gaba is known to have an inhibitory
effect over neuronial transmission
taurine has also been linked with the
mitochondria
it can be bound to transfer rnas that
are used to add amino acids into
proteins and so it therefore may play a
role in mitochondrial protein production
and taurine has also been linked with
oxidative stress a double-blind study
was conducted with 24 females who took
1.5 grams of taurine a day for 16 weeks
and after this time period those who
took taurine showed a higher level of
the enzyme superoxide that this mutase
albeit this was a very small trial and
didn't really look at too many markers
so that is what taurine is it seems to
be involved in many Pathways and the
research is still emerging
but why does one actually get taurine
well there are various sources of
taurine one of which is from Foods as
you can see in this table here
primarily it is found in both meats and
Seafoods and less so in meat products
like milk but rarely found in plants and
therefore vegetarian and vegan diets
have negligible amounts of taurine
although it is found in energy drinks
the typical American diet would provide
between 123 and 178 milligrams of
taurine daily
whilst those who are vegan have
essentially no taurine coming from their
diets
however our bodies also naturally make
it so it is conditionally essential
our bodies usually make enough
and you can see here that there are
enzymatic reactions that convert the
amino acid cysteine into taurine
now the fact that we possess enzymes
that make this compounds plus the fact
that touring is evolutionarily conserved
does hint at its importance indeed cats
who lack enzymes to make taurine must be
fair to diet high in taurine to prevent
them getting blindness and
cardiomyopathy
however even though our bodies can make
it and we can get it from food levels of
taurine decline with age and this is
where we begin with this recent
publication where they show that levels
decline by around 80 percent in humans
in blood serum and this decline is also
seen in mice and monkeys
and so given this decline of age and the
varying important roles of taurine the
researchers of this paper wanted to test
whether supplementing taurine could
reverse or delay some of the effects of
Adrian they gave touring to mice and
monkeys of different ages and measured
fairies markers of Health and Longevity
firstly they gave wild-type mice a
thousand milligrams per kilogram per
body weight once daily to middle aged
mice until the end of their life
and regardless of their sex taurine fed
mice survive younger than the control
mice both the median lifespan increased
being 10 to 12 percent longer for the
females than the males
and in these experiments both the
controls and the taurine fed mice had
free access to the same Foods showing
that this improved survival of taurine
fed mice was not a consequence of lower
survival of the control animals or
differences in the diets
they also saw us increased lifespan of
worms by 10 to 23 percent
now this is of course interesting but I
of course was interested in why this
might happen from a molecular basis a
mother this taurine supplementation has
benefits not just for lifespan but for
healthspan now the offers that do a
variety of measurements to examine
Health span further I will only present
some that I found more compelling for
example they gave taurine as a
supplement to aged rhesus monkeys to
assess healthspan markers arguably a
closer model to ask them the mice
and they found that given touring to
these monkeys it increased the bone
density and content in the lumbar spine
and legs although not in the heads
compared with control monkeys it also
reduced fasting blood glucose
concentrations by 19 under reduced the
serum concentrations of liver damage
markers and seen in this table here and
also with the mice Torin supplementation
decreased in age-associated increase in
senescence
however it is unlikely that reduced
senescence is the only way taurine is
acting as they gave senolytics to a
mouse model that were touring deficient
and found that it didn't fully recover
lifespan decline
and so essentially taurine may be
influencing senescence either the
initiation or the clearance of
senescence but that's not the whole
picture to how taurine is acting which
kind of makes sense given the number of
things it seems to be involved with that
we mentioned at the start of the video
what about human data well in the study
they performed an association analysis
of circulating taurine metabolite levels
with more than 50 clinical risk factors
and around 12 000 subjects of the Epic
Norfolk study they found that higher
blood taurine and high pretorian levels
were associated with lower body mass
index as well as high levels of taurine
metabolites being associated with a
lower prevalence of type 2 diabetes and
lower glucose levels
so although with this human data it is
Association and not causation along with
the mycin's monkey data these results do
seem to suggest that there are potential
benefits for taurine supplementation
with some of the benefits being greater
and females than males indicating that
there may also be some sex specific
Pathways that are being mediated by
taurine action
so obviously it'd be important to test
this further and one of the authors of
the study has said that they are looking
at a multi-centric multinational
intervention trial in humans to test
taurine further in particular they'd be
interested in trying to identify a safe
dose that can be employed albeit if we
translate from the mice to the human
studies it would approximate two doses
of around three to six grams of taurine
for an 80 kilogram person
But ultimately another interesting
question is why does the level of
taurine decline with age
an older study thought that it was due
to an age-dependent depletion of enzyme
activity in the liver that's involved in
generating taurine from cysteine
if this is the case then it might be
more important to our older ages to
restore levels of taurine to account for
this decline in endogenous production
but this decline could also be due to
changes in diets changes in the
absorption of taurine as well as just
changes in the production levels within
the body
it'd also be interesting to understand
when do these levels actually Decline
and are there any genetic links or
dietary influences
and so this fits with the author's
comments that they acknowledge that the
chemical mechanisms by which taurine
actually influence cells at a molecular
level are not fully understood
and at a press conference one of the
authors would not recommend that people
consume over-the-counter taurine
supplements to try to preserve health or
slow aging
and so whether it does slow down
hormones of Aging awaits further
confirmation however so far taurine has
been known to be safer consumption that
said I'm not here to influence or
promote anything I'm not a medical
doctor I just love the nerdy
biochemistry and think taurine is quite
a cool molecule
so my thoughts I hope you've enjoyed the
tea on touring thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening